the Labour MP Kelvin Hopkins was
suspended by the party this week as
allegations of inappropriate behavior
were about to be made public allegations
that were well-known to the party
leadership he's the second Labour MP to
lose the whip in as many weeks and
separately another investigation has
been launched into another Labour MP
Clive Lewis allegations he denies well
as I mentioned were joined by Labour's
shadow foreign secretary emily Thorne
very very good morning to my name um how
many complaints has the party received
how many active investigations are there
currently into labour politicians or
party members I don't know I don't know
what the exact number is I'm not
involved in the investigations I can
tell you that we what we've done we've
recently were in the process of setting
up a body which we think will be really
helpful which will be independent and
which will be there to give advice and
support and can be a first point of call
the thing is is that is there a lot of
what Theresa May is talking about is
about doing that and the focus and I
understand why but the focus is on
Westminster and what's happening in
Westminster actually we want to be a bit
more radical than that and we want to
talk about what may happen within the
Labour Party anywhere so whilst it's
fine to set up some sort of body in
relation to Westminster we need to make
sure that our processes that are already
kind of pretty robust but they've got to
be made stronger and that's why we've
got this new body and so people can
complain
can come forward and get support and put
in their complaint to this independent
body about people from the Labour Party
up and down the country if it's
something like that has happened
can we start though with with the
internal processes or Labour Party
Jeremy Corbyn Andrew Gwyn last week
where you were sitting suggested that
those procedures were robust they had
enough to deal with what's going on at
the moment the changes you're making
suggest that that that's demonstrably
untrue yeah yeah I mean I would have
thought that's right absolutely and we
need to make sure that we're now
changing I agree with you I think that I
hope that that this awful week will
result in something different and
something better coming from it because
and a step change to the way in which we
treat women particularly young women and
young men
within within our political process
because quite frankly what are we gonna
do without youngsters coming into the
into into politics I mean we will at
some point in the future be in a
position to review the changes that the
Labour Party is clearly making but at
this point in time we're in a position
to examine the way in which things have
gone
Beck's Bailey raised the issue of the
internal complaints procedure with the
NEC two years ago minute took her
bravery in coming out and talking about
her own personal experiences to force
the Labour leadership into actually
doing something about it
why well what I know happened was that
she was attacked in a terrible way that
she came forward a couple of years later
and spoke to people within the party and
as we've heard someone in the party
thought that it was it was a good piece
of advice to keep telling to keep her
head down and I'll say anything about it
and that was appalling
and of course we have to make sure we're
now looking into who that person was
what on earth they were thinking about
and also into Beck's and allegations and
that which need to be taken seriously I
would personally think they're probably
a matter for the police
but we need to make sure that this young
woman is supported but the leaders
office was aware of this it was only
when the media turned its attention to
this story that the party I didn't know
that the media was aware of this the
leaders office was aware of of an
alligator prank the party were clearly
aware that something there was a problem
experi had been pushing for the internal
complaints procedure to be updated for
quite some time it took are talking
about her accusation of rape for changes
to even be discussed I mean for a
progressive party I mean you're not just
letting down your members you're not
just letting down your politicians
you're letting down you know the young
people that are flocking to the party
and their drawers sure sure we talked
about Kelvin Hopkins well that's
difficult for me to talk about specific
cases can I just be given the word we
are investigating these matters just
like I would be wrong for me to talk
about Damien Green or you know or anyone
else it would be difficult for me to
talk about specific but we can talk
about what happened within the party he
heard that what he has now heard the
whip suspended as you mentioned there is
an investigation underway
but he was promoted to the labor front
bench in 2016 after he'd been
reprimanded by the quips
I mean why was he a man who had an
allegation of inappropriate sexual
behavior known to the Whip's office on
his record
why was he promoted to the front bench
no this is all part of the investigation
I'm really sorry I I don't want to come
on here and not answer questions but I'm
not in a position I'm going to be able
to but you can keep asking me but I'm
not gonna be attracted to went to the
leaders office at the time of his
promotion and said why on earth are we
doing this he's had a reprimand
we know that his behavior has been
subpar and still he was promoted now
that does go to the leaders office on
this occasion I don't know I don't know
I didn't know that Rosie wasn't still
still the chief whip at the time but if
there had been a change of width then I
don't know I mean the problem is that
the general Corbin cannot say that he
cannot complain I knew nothing of this
behavior okay sani danja was suspended
from the party back in 2015 December
2015 at exactly the same time that the
party knew about the allegations about
mr. Hopkins no similar cases entirely
dissimilar treatment one of them
suspended who happened to be a critic of
mr. Corin another of them promoted to
the front bench who just happens to be a
key ally now you can draw whatever
conclusions you want at this stage but I
am not in a position to be able to
comment on these matters in detail
because they are under investigation I
don't want you to go I don't well I'm
sorry but that's that's what you're
getting so I mean I'm happy to go but
I'm here to try and give you such
assistance as I'm able to but I am NOT
going to talk about internal discussions
at the moment where there is an
investigation going on it is not for me
an appreciator may be being a bit
loyally about this but whilst an
investigation is going on we let that
investigation take its course and and
not to get involved in in in in
commentary on it or you know additional
information or anything else I'm not
going to be doing that just like I'm not
going to be casting aspersions in
relation to any Tories you know or any
other case okay relation again it is
just I just can't do it and and I'm
sorry and I appreciate you may want to
push the story on but I'm just not in a
position to be helpful it's not whatever
I want to show you this we have some you
know there are a legitimate question
the moment about the judgement of Jeremy
called and I want you to take a look at
this that's the leader of the Opposition
the leader of your party being asked why
he promoted someone who'd been
reprimanded for inappropriate sexual
conduct
Teta treating an entirely legitimate
question with utter distinct no you
could see it another way couldn't you
which is so the leader of the Opposition
yet again being doorsteps yet again
people being outside his house and and
asking questions and him not wishing to
be involved in this in discussing
matters that are being investigated well
you knew about the allegations but
Kelvin Hopkins years ago he only had the
whip withdrawn after press reports Jared
mana similar situation allegations made
it put to the leaders office in
September party only took action where
party didn't even take action when the
press reported them he stood up at the
meeting of the PLP apologized and was
allowed to continue on the equalities
committee again it was only after
further press reports that he had the
whip with John Beck's Bailey you only
acted when the media got involved in all
of this yeah rather than treating the
media with disdain its mr. Corbin
clearly dead in there
he should be owing as a debt of
gratitude I think that the people who we
owe a debt of gratitude to all those who
have come forward with these allocations
and who have been brave in the way that
they have I think there's some of the
people who have come forward you have
seen a complete character assassination
going on in the media so don't start
with virtue waving at me it seems to me
that that we should be looking at the
victims of this and we should be making
sure that our parties respond
appropriately actually and and make sure
that we and they're out school parties
as you suggested it and and and and the
parties need to ensure that we put in
processes in place where people are
given proper support and where we can
change the
culture right let's not get involved in
a in a phony Rauh about this I want to
major I want to make sure that my party
that this sort of behavior does not
happen in my party I am ashamed of
what's been going on and I want us to do
something about it and we will do
something about it and we do something
about it
in in Parliament as a as a workplace as
Parliament can be a workplace and we can
have processes there but I want stuff
happening actually in my party so that
where there are allegations that happen
at Party events as Becks has said happen
to her but actually there's a process
there as well the people are supported
properly there are proper discussions
people are not being told but keep your
head down dear don't say anything that
the party actually supports people and
gives people appropriate advice which is
why we now are going to have an
independent body now you can you can try
you can try and and kind of cast
aspersions in relation to the party you
know as much as you like I cannot go in
theory and you see tails in relation to
allegations in the wind where the
individuals at the most operate because
there are allegations landing and are
being investigated on your briefing
you're soon traveling to Israel and
Palestine I'm sorry to shift but I do
want to specify we're not going to get
anywhere and I'm not so sure
I mean you attended a dinner and this
week with a Benjamin Netanyahu mr.
Corbyn it wasn't it wasn't available to
attend I mean do you think were further
from a two-state solution then we happen
for quite some time yes I'm afraid we
are so what is the solution the solution
is I think that you know when you talk
to people behind closed doors
politicians behind closed doors most of
them know what a two-state solution
looks like they know though they've been
talking about it for decades now what we
need is people to expend a bit of
political capital to be brave to take
the leap you know in order to be able to
move this process onwards but instead in
the meantime we have incitement on both
sides we have the continual battle we're
building of settlements and and we seem
to be moving into a situation where it
will be what we need to have is is to
viable States and the more settlements
that are built within the within the
Palestinian side of the border than what
the less viable Palestine becomes and
the more attacks that there are on
Israeli people from the Palestinian
the less trust there is from Israelis so
it needs to stop it would be it would be
fantastic to have some leads leadership
from the Americans at this stage but
whether we're going to get it or not is
a is a moot point
so the Balfour Declaration it seems to
me actually in the hundredth anniversary
reminds us that British politicians can
make a difference that we can show some
sort of world leadership and it seems to
me that that the hundredth anniversary
of the Balfour Declaration which did
talk about making sure that we respected
the rights of both it's about time that
we recognized the Palestinian state but
it could do that if 100th anniversary it
isn't a simple truth that no matter what
we say to the Israeli prime minister at
you know dinners and diplomatic
functions whatever they continue to
build they continue to build and there's
nothing we can do about it well I think
there is something that can be done
about it and I think that in the end you
know we get the conversation begins I
think with a two-state solution is
actually also in the interests of
Israelis who want there to be a
democratic largely Jewish state you
cannot have a one state solution that is
that is a Jewish Democratic state
because it'll be it'll mean it'll be
majority Palestinian and there will
always be a minority of Palestinians
within an Israeli state but and their
rights need to be need to be upheld but
you know to continue to build in the way
that they are actually I think that the
current Israeli government is letting
down the Israeli people because they are
driving a coach and horses through the
possibility of a two-state solution as a
point made by my own number of Israeli
citizens themselves absolutely yeah
emily Thorne
many thanks for being with us a problem